welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and i feel like an absolute clown as i
didn't think that disney invest today
was going to be this big dc
fandom-esque event however i'm happy to
be proven wrong with these
incredible announcements we're going to
be breaking it all down but i'm not
going to be covering stuff like the the
pixar panels and and stuff like that as
i know my audience brought you well and
i know all you care about
is the star wars and marvel ones there's
a lot to talk about and a huge shout out
to discussing film on twitter
for live tweeting this event as it's
massively helped me to compile my
thoughts
now it was announced that there will be
10 star wars and marvel properties
coming to disney plus
over the next couple of years and the
circus series is currently in the works
and that will be starring rosario dawson
as the character goes after grand
admiral thrawn
there's also going to be a ranges of the
new republic series
which though we don't know too much
about it's definitely something to keep
your eye on
andor aka cassian ando's series will
also release in 2022
and this will be set before the events
of rogue one because
spoiler alert the lads dead now we have
known for quite a while that there will
be an obi-wan series in production
starring you mcgregor however he sat
down yet
hayden christensen will be returning as
darth vader
for the big bad of the show this is
absolutely mind-blowing news
and mike zero has actually been calling
it for a while so
you know what give the lads some props
yeah now if you're a fan of the clone
wars you're probably sad it's come to an
end
however we will be getting star wars the
bad batch which is set to follow some
clone troopers
as they make their way through the
galaxy now for those of you that like
the dark side
don't worry we've got your fill here
with the acolyte which will be a mystery
thriller following the dark side
emerging
during the end of the high republic era
get ready to watch your boy lando
try and uh make love to some robots as
that character is also getting his own
spin-off too i'm sorry lando
i'm sorry i know you don't love robots
that much there's also star wars visions
which is sort of going to be a what if
series for the star wars universe
in that it's gonna be a bunch of
animated short films from iconic
japanese creators
now we did hear earlier in the week that
patty jenkins wasn't too happy with
warner brothers releasing their entire
slate for next year on hbo max
and it looks like she's done something
behind the scenes
she is going to be directing star wars
rogue squadron
which i'm sure if you hear that name you
get as hyped as i am
i've currently got goosebumps because
i'm such a fan of that game
and it's going to be amazing to see her
you know in the director's chair for
what could be an amazing series
taika watiti is also going to be
developing a fresh unexpected and unique
star wars movie
but at the moment we don't know all the
ins and outs of it
now lucasfilm of course owns many
properties
and it's also been announced that james
mangold is directing
indiana jones with harrison ford who's
set to return for the final time
so just to sum up the lucasfilm
announcement there's gonna be an ahsoka
series
hayden christensen is coming back as
darth vader we're getting lando in his
own show
patty jenkins will direct star wars
rogue squadron
and the acolyte will be a high republic
era series
now over to the marvel stuff as i'm sure
you're as excited to get into that as i
am
and we did get a new trailer for one
division this kind of showed
more wonders life living in the this
sitcom reality
and how they were kind of tackling with
what was going on that of course
releases in the middle of january
and it's going to be really interesting
to see how this entire thing is brought
to life
i think this show is going to kick start
a new era on disney plus
and if all of the series are as high
quality as this
then it's going to be absolutely amazing
it's been announced that acitel gomez
will be playing america chavez and
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
i've completely butchered her name but
you know what i got up at half one this
morning
recorded this entire breakdown it broke
so i've had to record it again so
apologies for that
feeling a bit worse for it now
throughout the week we've had a lot of
announcements throughout the week such
as charlie cox returning his daredevil
andrew garfield being set to reprice his
role as peter parker
and kevin feige confirmed that
spider-man 3
will be exploring the multiverse just in
case you didn't know that already which
i'm sure you did
i'm sounding a bit smug and that's
because the first trail of a falcon in
the winter soldier
has been released the series will drop
on march the 19th
so we're gonna we're basically gonna get
the mandalorian
have a couple of weeks of free time
where we do nothing on a friday
then one division's gonna drop that's
gonna run for six weeks
gonna have another break then falcon in
the winter soldier will be there
and then after that we're gonna get loki
yes
loki is coming in may 2021 and we also
got our first look at that which showed
the events of avengers end game
before branching off into the character
just doing his own thing you know
putting his feet up and having fun
in that loki's gonna be traveling
through time messing things up
and we also got a clip of him starring
as db cooper
which is a very interesting story that
you definitely should check out
the first trailer for what if has also
been dropped and this will show
alternate versions of our favorite
marvel characters doing things in an
animated universe
ms marvel is of course currently filming
at the moment and we got some looks at
that that were kind of comic book pages
and the creative team talking about
what's gonna happen in it now there are
a whole host of disney plus shows
similar to the star wars lineup
and we have known for a while that she
hulk will be coming very soon
however we didn't really know who was
going to be the villain of that and it
turns out that tim roth will be
returning as the abomination
he's not the only marvel character
making a return to the platform either
and secret invasion will be dropping
with samuel l jackson
and ben mendelsohn set to return we're
also getting a don
cheadle-led armor wars which will slowly
branch off into iron heart
starring dominic thorne as riri williams
christian bale has been announced this
starring as gor the butcher and thor
love and thunder
and though james gunn is currently over
at dc
he will be making a return to marvel to
direct the guardians of the galaxy
holiday special
catherine newton will also star as
cassie lang and
jonathan mages will be appearing as kang
the conqueror
in ant-man and the wasp quantomania the
fantastic four is in the works with john
watts set to direct
and kevin feige has confirmed that black
panther will not be recast for black
panther ii
so lots of things to to talk about there
namely falcon in the winter soldier
which will be appearing on march 19th
captain marvel 2 is definitely coming
with brie larson
though some people don't think that
she's going to be in it for some reason
catherine newton is going to be cassie
lang there's going to be iron heart
armor wars a guardians of the galaxy
holiday special
and secret invasion disney plus shows
fantastic four is going to be directed
by john watts
and there's just a hell of a lot of
things to talk about
now i've had to rush you all that
because there's just so many things to
unpack
but you know when you're boy i need my b
you sleep quite a lot
but when i'm getting up at half one in
the morning to cover this stuff
you know it's big news i didn't say that
it wasn't going to be a big event but
very happy to be a proven wrong and once
again a complete clown
i thought this was gonna be cc xp yeah
don't judge me
absolutely incredible though and
obviously i'll be bringing you full
breakdowns of all the series as they air
and i'm just so excited for the next
year now we're starting to wrap up the
video but don't forget we're giving away
three copies of the lord of the rings 4k
box set and all you have to do to be
with the chance of winning is make sure
you subscribe to the channel
leave a like and drop your thoughts in
the comment section below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of december so make sure you
get involved
if you enjoyed this video i'd love it if
you stuck around at the channel
and if you want something else to watch
then we've done a full breakdown of
everything we know so far about
spider-man 3 which is going to be linked
at the end
that's going to be appearing on screen
now so make sure you click it
and i'll see you next time i love you
and sorry for rushing through all this
but uh but but remember yeah i love you
take care
peace